so apparently andrew cuomo is pinning
the covid deaths in new york city
squarely on millennials
not his own dumb policies but
millennials and cuomo has made a cool
new youtube channel
to get his important public service
announcements out however
it looks like andrew cuomo doesn't feel
very confident about his messages
because he's disabled the comment
section and the like and dislike buttons
on his new channel so in an effort to
help you fully
enjoy the experience of andrew cuomo's
youtube channel
my producer is now going to play a video
from his channel
and i will fill out the comments section
let's roll it
yo what up dogs paul rudd here actor and
certified young person
a few days ago i was talking on the
iphone with my homie governor cuomo
and he's just going off about how us
millennials need to wear masks
because get this apparently a lot of
covid is transmitted by us millennials
no cap stop there
so the setup is actually pretty funny
and paul rudd is a good performer and
the writing is not even that bad
the premise is completely ridiculous
because andrew cuomo killed thousands of
elderly people through bad policies in
new york state
but at least the comedy setup is kind of
funny
keep going so qualms asked me he's like
paul you gotta help
what are you like 26 and i didn't
correct him
so fam let's real talk masks
they're totally beast so slide that into
your dms and twitch it
bob check yes queens like ourselves we
want to go to bars
we want to drink hook up do our tick
tocks i get it
i'm not going to preach at you like some
celebrity look
this is a combo where i talk and you
shut up and wear your mask
all right it's fuzzy there so it it's
i'm sorry i'll keep typing my comment
it's still pretty funny
because paul rudd obviously is not 26
years old
and because this is obviously not how
millennials talk and actually the young
generation isn't even millennials at
zoomers
so the whole thing is is a basically
well done version
of an old guy trying to seem like a
young cool guy kind of like that steve
buscemi clip
where he says how do you do fellow kids
all in all so good but it kind of
undercuts cuomo's point because cuomo
wants to seem hip and he wants to seem
like his message is earnest but right
now the whole thing is
is very ironic
keep playing oh hi billy eilish
what's that you're wearing your mask
man i want to stan you you're so my bae
yo listen hype beasts masks protect you
and your dank squad because caring about
other people
is the new not caring about people
so pause pause right there so the the
message he's saying
is being delivered very well in the way
that these sorts of messages are
delivered right in an ironic video
but the way this would typically be
delivered
is like whatever he's saying he really
means the opposite
so it's actually just ironic except that
the thing he's saying is ostensibly the
message
the governor wants to put out so you're
in a kind of weird position right now
where he he's undercutting what he's
saying but it's basically entertaining
while he doesn't i mean i agree with him
i think it's
lame and contrived and ridiculous to
tell people to do all of this nonsense
but is that is that what cuomo believes
does cuomo all of a sudden agree with me
and a lot of other conservatives
sounds great
keep rolling you want a challenge how
about a
stop the pandemic challenge what about
that what about a saved grandma
challenge
that fun enough for you my name is paul
and i'm six feet tall almost and oops
i wear my mask and it's all i ask that
you wear your mask
please wear your mask just wear a mask
just wear
a mask it's easy it's simple please it's
not hard people are dying
hundreds of thousands of people are
dying hold it hold it
here we go here's where the thing falls
apart because then they break the fourth
wall and they do what all of these
lefties keep doing specifically on the
mask issue but they do it on any other
political issue that they don't have
good arguments for
is then they just start yelling at you
and start using swear words and say just
wear the effing mask
just do the just do it it's so it's not
hard just do it please
well it's so hard about it it's like
bill nye does this whole thing just
starts yelling
and he thinks that if you yell swear
words loud enough that that's somehow an
argument so you take a video that was
previously funny
making the opposite point that paul rudd
and cuomo are making now
and then it just becomes this unfunny
scolding session
based on a bunch of bs
keep going it's preventable just wear a
mask i shouldn't have to make it fun
it's science it's it's science
pause it it's science
it's science it's science is the new
god wills it you know in the crusades
the the crusaders
yelled deus vult god wills it that's the
new that's the secular
false version of that is it's science
how is it science
if it's science that we all need to wear
masks all the time
do you see a problem with how paul rudd
is convincing us of that
do you see do you see any problem with
it he's not wearing a mask
continue
look at this hey hey look at us look at
us
who would have thought wearing masks
would be a problem not me
we gotta eat this virus
so you saw at the end there he has the
mask on with that other guy but it's a
filthy mask and it's got chicken grease
all over
which is actually one of the issues with
the masks is that even if the masks
themselves used perfectly
could be helpful people don't use them
correctly and often they'll touch their
face
and get their fingers all over their
mouth and their nose and their ears and
everything
so sometimes you're getting even more
facial contact than you would otherwise
which is not good for the spread
of any virus but even in the first part
right he does the whole video without
wearing a mask
and it's not as though he's alone in a
room right there he's in a studio
and he's got an entire crew all around
him shouldn't he be wearing the mask if
it's so important to wear the mask all
the time
pretty lame stuff started out as a good
video but then just got typical and
preachy and lame and it turns out they
don't even understand
the comedic point they were making in
the first place
i do not like this video
you